- Every time I get in the car,
and I'm thinking,
"Is this the one that's
gonna beat me to death?"
- [Mark] Alright, Jackie.
- [Jackie] Yes.
- [Mark] Jackie, where'd you grow up,
where are you from, originally?
- [Jackie] Lafayette,
California, raised in Watts.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both of your
parents when you were a kid?
- I never knew my father, and, my mom
abandoned me when I was two years old.
When my grandmother found me,
I had to learn how to walk again
because I was so malnourished
that I couldn't walk.
So as I grew up, she had a daughter, and,
I wasn't treated like her daughter.
I beat, her daughter didn't get beat.
I ran away several times.
I always ended up going back.
By the time I was 16, 16-17,
I was raped by my teacher.
Imagine that.
She didn't believe me.
So she sent me to Kaiser.
- [Mark] To where?
- Kaiser.
It's a mental hospital, Kaiser.
She thought I had a sex problem,
and he said basically the
same thing that she said.
"I asked for it."
So I figured if everybody felt that way,
I don't have to be here, why am I here?
I never felt loved.
I never understood what love was.
(sniffles)
So I reached out for
love in different ways.
- [Mark] Do you feel
like you were ever loved?
- I still don't feel like I'm loved.
How can I feel loved if I
don't know how to love myself?
Can't nobody do nothing to
me that I do worse to myself.
I treat myself worse than
anybody, anybody ever could,
because I don't think
I deserve to be happy.
I put myself in deadly
situations on a daily basis.
I don't have people watching my back.
As tiny as I am, I'm not
afraid to walk down the street
and get in cars with two
or three different men.
I've had guns pointed to my head.
I've been beat.
I've been stabbed here, I almost died.
I didn't know this was gonna
be this hard, I'm sorry.
And then on top of that,
I started getting high,
and that didn't help either.
(sniffles)
Sometimes I wonder why am I here?
There's no purpose for me here.
Why did God put me here?
Everybody that come in
contact with me, I hurt.
So what's my point?
- [Mark] Your childhood was so rough that
you never learned to love yourself.
- I never felt it, so I
don't know what it is.
For some reason I think
it's supposed to hurt.
- [Mark] Do you think that's what maybe
attracts a lot of women
to this lifestyle is...
- Low self-esteem, and
they don't know how...
They don't think they deserve to be happy.
At least that's what I feel.
I can't talk for nobody else,
but I feel that I don't
deserve to be happy.
- [Mark] Because this lifestyle
kind of provides treatment that's...
- And then when I get high,
it takes that thought
away for a little while,
and I forget about it,
but then when I come down
and have to get high,
more (indistinct) to
get high all over again
to make the thoughts go away.
It's like suicidal.
I was just too scared to do it that way,
so I do it different ways.
Cause in the back of my mind,
I really do want to die.
I want to die.
- [Mark] You started working
the street at what age?
- 17.
- [Mark] I'm sure you've
had bad experiences.
- Yeah.
But it was weird though,
because when I started,
I was hungry, and I was
just walking down...
Where was I?
Somewhere on Broadway.
And I was just walking down the street,
and this guy, he seemed real nice.
He said, "You need a ride?"
So I got in the car.
He says, now I never done this,
he says, "I've got $24,
can we do something?"
I said, "Yeah."
And it was quick and easy.
Next few times was quick and easy,
but then I met that one
person that wanted to beat me.
Took the money back...
When you're...I kept doing it.
And I'm still doing it.
I'm 54 years old.
- [Mark] You still working?
- Yeah.
Eventually something has to change.
I'm getting too old, but
I don't know nothing else.
- [Mark] Is this all you've ever done?
- All I've ever done.
I love to read though.
I love to read.
I'm very intelligent.
I'm an intelligent, stupid person.
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- I have many children.
- [Mark] Three?
- I have a gang of children.
- [Mark] How many?
- I have nine living and three deceased.
- [Mark] So you lost some.
- I lost three at one time.
They died in a car accident.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- Yeah, so altogether I have 12.
All of them drug addicted but one.
- [Mark] All of what?
- All of them were born with
drugs in they system but one.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah, I never raised none of them.
- [Mark] And you're still using today?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Crack?
- [Mark] Okay.
- Can you imagine what your
life might've been like
if you had loving parents
and a good childhood?
- [Jackie] I see other people like that,
but I just can't see me that way.
- [Mark] Can't picture it.
- [Jackie] No.
- [Mark] That's a shame.
- [Jackie] It's a short
story, but it's mine.
I don't know what else to do.
- [Mark] I'm sure it gets you depressed.
- [Jackie] Yeah, I take
depression medication.
- [Mark] You do?
- [Jackie] Yeah.
Cause I get depressed, I get suicidal, so,
They don't want me getting depressed.
- [Mark] Have you tried suicide?
- [Jackie] Yeah, that's
why I stopped taking,
I don't take pills anymore.
I don't like pain that way, so.
I'm scared of blood, so.
I walked out in front of a car before.
Then (indistinct).
I'm still trying to
figure out, why am I here?
Then they say he don't make mistakes,
but I don't believe
that cause I think I am.
- [Mark] And the guys who pick
you up, tell me about them.
- [Jackie] Oh, you got
a bunch of weird ones.
You got some nice ones, you do.
But you get more strange
ones than you're getting.
You got some that are nice, and
they just want your company.
And you have some that want to be dominant
and want you to crawl around on the floor.
And then you just got
some weird ones that when,
once you, they want to piss all on you.
Or, watch them shit in a paper
bag and smear it all on them.
It's weird, I do have some weird ones.
- [Mark] What's the hardest
part of this lifestyle for you?
- Right now?
Every time I get in the car,
and thinking is this the one
that's going to beat me to death?
And the weird part about it though,
I don't know if that's
the hard part or not
because I smile and get in the car.
- [Mark] You do it anyway.
- I do it anyway.
That's what they say insanity is, right?
Doing the same thing
expecting different results.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- When I had my first baby.
When I first looked at him,
I tell you, I was happy then,
that two seconds, when they
put the baby right here.
And you look down (indistinct).
Then I said, "What the hell
am I gonna do with this?"
It's crazy.
I like the way it feels when pregnant.
I like the fact something's
growing inside of me.
But then when they come out,
I don't know do it with only one of them.
- [Mark] Did you raise your kids?
- No.
- [Mark] Who raised them?
- I raised my first
child for like two weeks.
I can't do it mentally, I can't.
So, the system,
family, couple fathers.
One is a couple of them.
I don't even know what they look like.
I seen them, when they took them out,
but I couldn't tell you
what they look like.
If they walked up and
stood in front of me,
I couldn't tell you what they looked like.
- [Mark] How do you think your years
of working the streets has changed you?
- I still try to be a nice person.
I still say just cause I'm in the streets,
the streets don't have to be in me.
I still try to treat people
the way I want to be treated,
but there's a flip side.
There's people (indistinct)
I can be the nicest person you wanna meet,
until you draw first blood.
Then it's my turn.
I'm very patient.
You might not never know it's
me, but I'm gonna get you.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- [Jackie] Whatever you
do, no matter what it is...
You gonna be a dope head?
Be the best dope head you can be.
And you gonna be a hooker?
Be the best hooker you can be.
Don't half step in nothing.
That don't make sense to you, does it?
Does it?
- [Mark] Okay.
- This is all I know, so, I'm
gonna be the best I can be.
Put your best foot forward.
- [Mark] Alright, Jackie.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
Can I go now?
- [Mark] You're beautiful.
(chuckles)
I think you're beautiful!